[MUSIC PLAYING]
PETE FRISELLA: --tech
lead for the API.
He is the guy who actually
builds this thing and makes
this great API that a
lot of people use.
And I'm really excited
to have here today
to talk about some--
JEETENDRA SONEJA: Happy
to be here.
PETE FRISELLA: --issues about
quotas and things like that.
So, this is great.
JEETENDRA SONEJA: Great.
PETE FRISELLA: So we're going
to start off from agenda
perspective, talk a little bit
why we have quotas, like
what's the point of quotas.
A couple things about best
practices, and then how you
can plan for growth.
And also some of the common
errors that people experience
and issues they might have.
So we'll start off
with quotas.
Why do we have quotas?
Like what's the point
of quotas?
And what are the quotas
that we actually have?
And which ones are the ones that
you might come up against
during your daily usage
of the API?
JEETENDRA SONEJA: Right.
So let's talk about why
do we have quotas.
So a lot of the APIs within
Google and outside of Google,
we have some standard quotas and
some API-specific quotas.
So the main purpose for the
quotas is to manage resources.
At Google they have limited
servers, limited resources,
and we need to make sure that
everybody, all developers, out
there are getting equitable
access and sharing their
resources in a fair manner.
So that's one main purpose.
And the other is protecting our
systems from abuse, maybe
intentional or unintentional.
That could be some buggy program
that may just go into
an infinite loop and just
overload our servers.
And that could affect other
developers who are actually
doing the right thing.
So we need to have this
production in place to make
sure that we are serving
our users right.
And at the end of the day, it's
for both, for developers,
as well as us that we have
these quotas in place.
PETE FRISELLA: Sure, yeah.
JEETENDRA SONEJA: Quotas
is what is
the type of the request.
So if you think about it, we
have different features, and
hence different types
of requests.
So, for example, a Get request,
or Read Only request,
is very different from an Upload
request, which can
actually incur some rights to
additional CPU processing.
So we need to consider that
when we come up with these
different quota policies.
And remember, the underlying
theme is you're trying to all
the quota numbers that we have
are an arbitrary number.
So we just look at all the use
cases, make sure we are not
restricting any use case,--
PETE FRISELLA: Sure.
JEETENDRA SONEJA: --enabling all
the things that developers
want to do, all the great
apps they want to build.
And at the same time,
product our system.
PETE FRISELLA: Yeah.
JEETENDRA SONEJA: And, finally,
all of these quotas
are associated with some
kind of entity.
All of our quotas are
per-product quotas, so this
could be like QPS per project or
a number of-- like the one
that we have, the most common is
daily request per project,
which is 50,000.
PETE FRISELLA: Yeah.
JEETENDRA SONEJA: And
then there are some
entity-specific--
per-profile or per-property
quotas.
PETE FRISELLA: OK.
Great.
So let's take a look around the
quotas that we actually
have that most people
come up against.
So we have other quotas, and
we'll provide resources later.
And we can go in and read
documentation that explains
all the different quotas
that we might have.
So we just want to cover some
of the main ones, the big
ones, that people are often
requesting or asking for more
information about.
The first one is going back to
Jeentendra when he was talking
about around the general quotas
that we have that apply
to all APIs.
The biggest one is that
we have is the 50,000
requests per day.
So this is the currency
limit that we give
you in terms of quota.
JEETENDRA SONEJA: It's
a good distinction.
So we have quotas that some are
based on user entities or
user-level quotas.
So this one is an example of
user-level quotas, since a
profile belongs to a user.
PETE FRISELLA: Yes.
JEETENDRA SONEJA: And then
the per-project ones are
developer- or app-specific
quotas.
PETE FRISELLA: Exactly.
And then, finally, we have the
10 concurrent requests per
second on a per-profile basis.
And this is tied to the
IP address, right?
JEETENDRA SONEJA: Right.
PETE FRISELLA: Yeah.
JEETENDRA SONEJA: So this is
actually per profile, so if
you have, let's say long-running
requests, you
need to wait for those requests
for that profile--
for single profile--
to finish.
Again, if you're sending us 10
long-running requests, it's
probably better to wait for the
response from some of them
before you send additional
requests.
PETE FRISELLA: Yeah.
Also, in terms of what can be
increased, neither one of
these can actually be
increased, right?
JEETENDRA SONEJA: Right.
PETE FRISELLA: But this goes
back to what Jeetendra had
talked about, how we look at--
we look at usage history, we
look at how people are
using the API.
I think these quotas cover like
99% of use cases, right?
JEETENDRA SONEJA: Right.
PETE FRISELLA: So for most
users this is actually--
JEETENDRA SONEJA: Yeah, if you
look at the numbers, like
10,000 requests per profile,
that seems pretty generous.
If you think about the use
cases, because 10,000 seems
like a lot of requests for a
profile for a single day.
PETE FRISELLA: Sure.
JEETENDRA SONEJA: Even though
you might have a lot of data,
that's a lot of requests.
PETE FRISELLA: For sure.
Yes, so let's talk a little
bit about best practices.
How you get the most out of the
quota that you're given
from the courtesy perspective.
So what's really important
is the API's console.
So this is your starting point
for a lot of things that have
to do with quota and
managing your usage
around analytics APIs.
To make sure you're really
getting all the full quota
that you're given from a
starting point, from a default
standpoint, you want to make
sure that you've got an API's
console front.
So some people--
JEETENDRA SONEJA: [INAUDIBLE].
PETE FRISELLA: Yeah.
So you can set it from
anywhere from--
I think you can even do it less
than one and use in this
case, I think.
But there's no point in setting
it higher than 10
queries per second.
And if you're an individual
developer that's working on
your only single profile, then
you might as well just set it
to 10, if you want, because
you're not really trying to
rate-limit anybody, right?
JEETENDRA SONEJA: Right, yeah.
That could be your
default value.
PETE FRISELLA: Yeah, and the
reason you might want to do
that is that you don't want a
single user out of all your
users eating up most of your
quota, because they may be
making more requests
[INAUDIBLE].
JEETENDRA SONEJA: Right,
right, this is a useful
utility that you should make
use of, depending on the
nature of your app.
PETE FRISELLA: Sure, yeah.
And then finally, there's this
reports pane, that I'm not
sure if everybody's aware of
this, but it's really great,
because you can come in
to the API's console.
And there's a couple things
you can do with this.
One is just see how much you are
using in terms of requests
on a daily basis, but also
give you some information
around where people are coming
from that are making requests,
like where they're located.
And then there's stuff you
can do for diagnostics.
There's error rates in here.
And you can see of all the
requests you're making, what's
the error rate that you might
have, because you want to keep
that low and make sure you
don't want to be spending
quota on error rates, right?
JEETENDRA SONEJA: Right.
PETE FRISELLA: So this is a
great way to check out how
things are working.
Also, if you see zero in here,
that means you haven't
properly associated your
request with your API's
console project.
So you should see some
usage in your--
JEETENDRA SONEJA: It's
a very handy utility.
I think you should totally
make use of it.
It gives you a lot of insights
into are you
doing the right things.
What your growth pattern
looks like, and so on.
PETE FRISELLA: Sure.
JEETENDRA SONEJA: So let's talk
about handling different
kinds of errors.
So, like we talked about, there
are some short-term
quotas a and long-term quotas.
PETE FRISELLA: Yeah.
JEETENDRA SONEJA: So for the
short-term ones, like QPS base
limits, you should probably
handle those by implementing
some kind of rate limiting.
So what we mean by rate limiting
is so, if you think
about it, 10 requests per
second, again, seems like
quite a few requests
per second.
So if you are trying to make
requests too fast, you will
see these errors, rate-limiting
errors.
PETE FRISELLA: Sure.
JEETENDRA SONEJA: And what you
need to is basically slow down
a bit, implement some
kind of technique.
One of such techniques is
exponential backoff, where you
actually, basically, slow down
by using some kind of delay.
And the way you do it is you
start with some default value
and then you basically start
increasing that exponentially,
until you stop seeing
those errors.
So it's one of the techniques,
again, you could have whatever
technique you may want to use,
that suits your app.
But the idea is to slow
down deficiency in
your short-term errors.
Another example of short-terms
errors is concurrent quota,
where you may be making a lot
of requests per profile.
So in that case, again, you
should just wait for some of
those requests to finish,
before you send next
[? server ?] request.
PETE FRISELLA: Yeah?
OK.
JEETENDRA SONEJA: And--
PETE FRISELLA: Error rate,
what's typical for an error
rate that we want to see?
JEETENDRA SONEJA: Right, so on
the error rate, I think like
Pete just mentioned, in the
API's console you see all the
different statistics, one
of those is error rates.
So you should keep an eye on
that on a regular basis to
make sure that the
error rate--
typically we recommend
your error rate
should be below 1-3%.
If it's anywhere above that,
you should probably look at
your app, see what you're doing,
what you could be doing
different to bring down
that error rate.
PETE FRISELLA: Yeah.
JEETENDRA SONEJA: And lastly,
I would mention is that
handling errors is essential.
Like quota errors, you should
be programming for those,
because that leads to a better
user experience, rather than
user seeing some weird error.
You can actually be more
transparent and let them know
what's going on.
So one of the other things that
you could do, again, with
the help of the API's console
is plan for growth.
This is one of the techniques
that you can use to deal with
both short-term as well
as long-term quotas.
So for example, you can keep an
eye on the number of users
that you have, what your growth
pattern is looking like.
You can look at your 30-day
window to see what's your max,
what's your minimum number
of daily number of
requests that you have.
PETE FRISELLA: Sure.
JEETENDRA SONEJA: And you
could use some of the
optimizing techniques.
So for example, are you making
too many requests?
Just use the same data, so--
In a couple of slides, we'll
actually give an example of
this, where you could actually
optimize requests to request
the same amount of data
in a fewer requests.
So you could save on the
number of requests.
PETE FRISELLA: Yeah, caching
is a huge one.
I think a lot of people don't
take advantage of
caching on their end.
So I look at user requests for
quota increases, I see that
people make the same request
over and over--
And I know they're trying to
refresh data, which is what--
JEETENDRA SONEJA: Right.
PETE FRISELLA: --
[INAUDIBLE].
Yeah, caching can definitely
save you a lot of quota.
JEETENDRA SONEJA: Right, that's
a very good one too.
So caching, especially for data
that doesn't change that
often, like--
PETE FRISELLA: Management
API [INAUDIBLE].
JEETENDRA SONEJA:
Yeah, exactly.
Management API configuration
data.
How often do people update their
accounts or profiles?
Maybe once in a while?
So you can cache it for a few
hours, for four day or so,
again, depending on the
nature of your app.
PETE FRISELLA: Sure.
JEETENDRA SONEJA: But you should
definitely use some
form of caching to, again,
get the maximum of
your existing quotas.
PETE FRISELLA: Yeah, great.
So how do you actually make
a quota increase?
Now we understand, obviously,
that we provide courtesy
limits that work really well
for most developers.
But, of course, at some point,
you might grow your user base
and you want some more quota.
So how do you actually
go about doing that?
So, again, start back at
the API's console.
If you go to the quotas pane,
you'll see that there's a link
that says "request more".
And that'll kick off the whole
process, where you're filling
in some information on what
you're looking for in terms of
quota, how does your app work.
But some of the things you
probably want to look at and
start off with thinking about
before you make your quota
request is you want to make
sure you review the quota
documentation that we have.
So when you click that link,
you'll get some other links
that will send you some docs
that you can review what the
quota limits are, understand
things about like setting
per-user limits.
So these are important things
that before you make the
request, you might be able to
resolve the request before
actually making the request.
So it's good to check
that documentation.
Another thing is make sure
you've optimized your request.
And this just goes back
to can you maybe
consolidate a couple requests?
Can you save on quota before
you're actually requesting
more, right?
JEETENDRA SONEJA: Right.
PETE FRISELLA: This will help
you for long-term planning.
We want to see a
low error rate.
We said 1-3%, that seems like
a pretty reasonable error
rate, if you're doing proper
error handling.
And the reason we want to see
low error rate is we don't
really want to scale up your
error rate as you go along.
So if it's 20%, and we give
you from 50 to a million
requests per day, or 100,000
requests per day, you're just
scaling those errors up
with that request.
So we want to see that error
rate [INAUDIBLE]
JEETENDRA SONEJA: Yeah, but make
sure you're making the
max out of what you
have before you
ask for more quota--
PETE FRISELLA: Exactly, yeah.
JEETENDRA SONEJA: And also,
remember, a lot of these
errors are counting towards
your daily quota.
So it's better for the app to
actually nor do too many
errors, because at the end of
the day they would get counted
against your daily quota.
PETE FRISELLA: Exactly, yeah.
And I've seen requests come in
where 50% of the quota is
being used for just errors.
They're not handled proper rate
limiting [INAUDIBLE].
So that's a pretty
important one.
And use the API's console to
check those values, right?
And then, when you do make the
request, that's just helpful
if you explain the growth
estimates and where you're
coming from.
If it's a new app, we
understand, you might haven't
had any usage yet, but you're
planning for maybe a launch or
something like that.
That's fine.
Just send us a note through
the forum, let us know how
many users you're planning,
how many requests you're
making per users on average.
And just give us some kind of
general guideline on what you
think usage might look like.
And then we can always
ramp that up.
So I typically will suggest,
give us a reasonable amount of
quota, let's launch, and
see where we're at.
And then we can grow
from there.
That's not a problem.
JEETENDRA SONEJA: Right, right,
the more information
you give us, the more
transparent you are, the
easier it is for us to review
the whole thing and get back
to as soon as possible.
PETE FRISELLA: Exactly.
And then if you have an existing
app, we would like to
see that you are actually
currently using a good chunk
of your quota.
And this goes back to planning
your growth.
You don't want to come
in at the last minute
and make the request.
You want to look and say, OK,
we're at 80% of usage of our
quota, we should probably make
a quota request today.
And 80% is kind of a loose
number, but I think that's
pretty reasonable.
You should be using at
least 80% before
you make the request.
JEETENDRA SONEJA: That's
[INAUDIBLE].
PETE FRISELLA: All right, so
let's take a look at errors
and common problems that people
might have that we see
quite often when they make
requests, and maybe not
handling 403s properly.
And also with the error
messages [INAUDIBLE]
that they would see
probably, right,
when they make requests?
JEETENDRA SONEJA: Exactly.
So, yeah, like I said before, if
you get errors, you should
probably program for those and
handle them gracefully.
So let's talk about the
different kinds of errors that
you get as quota errors.
PETE FRISELLA: Sure.
JEETENDRA SONEJA: 403 is the
response code that you get for
all for all HTTP response code
for all the different types of
quota errors.
And then you see a reason or a
code that will tell you what
kind of quota error
you're getting.
So one of the examples is
dailyLimitExceeded.
As the name suggests, you
are exceeding some
kind of daily limit.
PETE FRISELLA: Yeah.
JEETENDRA SONEJA: So ideally, if
you did your planning right
like what Pete was mentioning,
if you looked at your numbers
and you are not close to your
daily limit, you should
probably never see this error.
So if you're estimating your
traffic, tracking your growth
pattern, hopefully this
should not happen.
But if--
PETE FRISELLA: It does happen.
JEETENDRA SONEJA:
It does happen.
PETE FRISELLA: You get
surges of users.
It does happen, but, yeah,
definitely planning
beforehand.
JEETENDRA SONEJA: Right.
[INAUDIBLE].
PETE FRISELLA: You might as well
send us an email, even if
you're maybe a month out, you
might want to send an email
saying, look, I think the way
we're grown right now, we're
not 80%, but we're going to
be in a month from now.
Can I just pin you, and when
we hit this limit, so I can
get something--
We can at least know
what's going on
with the app forehead.
JEETENDRA SONEJA: Exactly.
So if this does happen, our
recommendation is you should
probably just stop making--
because [? retraining ?] is
not going to happen.
PETE FRISELLA: [INAUDIBLE].
JEETENDRA SONEJA: When you
finish your daily quota, you
need to wait for the next
24-hour period to take in in
order to get the new
round of quotas.
And that happens at Pacific
midnight, night time.
So you need to wait till
that before you get
new round of quota.
The other kind of quota errors
are around wait limiting.
Like if you are hitting
the service too
hard you would see--
Like if you're exiting the 10
QPS limit, you would see
userRateLimitExceeded.
Again, like I mentioned before,
just implement some
kind of throttling or just slow
down, implement, maybe
make use of some kind of
[? exponential ?] backoff.
And those should go away.
Those are the kinds of errors
that you can actually deal
with in an automated fashion,
like the slow down, and it
should go up.
Whereas daily, you just have
to stop making the request.
PETE FRISELLA: And
what's Unreg?
I think it says Unreg
versus this other
one that's over here?
JEETENDRA SONEJA: Right, so
that one is, since it says
Unreg, it's about
registration.
So this means that either you
haven't registered and sending
us unregistered traffic.
So you need to go sign up
in the API's console.
The other thing could be maybe
you have registered, but for
some reason your set up is
incorrect, and you're not
propagating the project
ID in your request.
So you either need to set up
OAuth2, which we strongly
recommend that you do that.
That way, you don't have
to worry about this.
You would never see this
if you're using OAuth2.
But for some reason, if you
cannot use OAuth2, you could
use the key parameter to
pass your API key.
PETE FRISELLA: Sure, OK.
JEETENDRA SONEJA: And lastly,
there are other quota errors,
like concurredQuotaExceeded,
or quotaExceeded is
the code for that.
Again, the idea there is to just
slow down first round of
request to finish.
And then you should be good.
PETE FRISELLA: Sure,
OK, great.
So the 10,000 requests per
profile, this is a common
request we get for
increases here.
And so typically the quoted
meets the needs of actually
probably about 100% people on
the 10,000 requests, I'd say.
But we do see a common case
for this in terms of why
they're getting this limit.
So I've got two examples here.
We're just go through quickly,
explain probably what's
usually happened.
So often when I see that people
are hitting this limit,
what they're doing is, for
example, they're making one
request per day.
So they want to see over time
on a daily basis maybe
something like visits.
And they'll actually make a
request for visits for the
June 6th, they'll make a
request for June 7th.
And, basically, every
day they're
making a single request.
JEETENDRA SONEJA: Right.
PETE FRISELLA: So you're making
n requests for the
amount of days that you
want data for, right?
So when you're doing a query
like this, what you want to
look is possibly can you
add a dimension?
In this case, you would want
to add a date dimension.
JEETENDRA SONEJA: Right.
PETE FRISELLA: And
then re-query
for the entire period.
And that would break out your
results by date, and you could
parse it out on your
end to actually the
day that you want.
So this actually happens quite a
bit that we see this type of
request be made.
Another one we see quite often
is, for example, you might
want to have something like,
what are my visits for every
page on my site?
And you want to actually do it
for each URL on your site.
So when people will make a
request for visits, use a
filter, and use something like
pagePath, for example.
And they'll set pagePath equal
to the pagePath that they're
interested in for visits, and
they'll get one result back.
So for every page you
want data for,
you to make a request.
If you have 10,000 pages on your
site-- which some sites
isn't a lot, some
sites it is--
you basically eat up all your
quota getting that data.
So you can only make one request
for all your sites or
all your pages in one day.
JEETENDRA SONEJA: Just one
type of data, yeah.
PETE FRISELLA: And if you want
to refresh [INAUDIBLE], you
can, right?
So the solution for that really
is that, again, you
should remove the filter and
add a pagePath dimension.
With the API you can create up
to 10,000 results in one
request, right?
So you could get all those
10,000 results in one shot.
JEETENDRA SONEJA: [INAUDIBLE].
PETE FRISELLA: So you went from
10,000 requests to one
request, and you get
the same data.
And then you parse it, again,
you parse it on your end to
get the actual visits
[INAUDIBLE], is that right?
JEETENDRA SONEJA: Right.
And for both these requests and
in general what you are
seeing for when users say, OK,
we are hitting this quota,
what do we do now?
PETE FRISELLA: Yeah.
JEETENDRA SONEJA: Like Pete gave
in both these examples,
if you notice there's generally
a pattern for these
kinds of requests that they're
trying to make smaller, really
small requests, and they're to
fetch data in smaller chunks,
and then stitch it on
the client side.
So what you could do--
that's such a [INAUDIBLE]
pattern that we see when
people hit this limit.
So like we said, the way you
can solve it is make one
comprehensive request, or one
overarching request that gets
all that data--
PETE FRISELLA: All data.
JEETENDRA SONEJA: --in
a single request.
And then, in fact, that will
save you all the stitching
that you're doing on the
client side, so.
PETE FRISELLA: This is actually,
I would say 99% of
the time when we get this
10,000-request quota increase
that people are trying to get
increases, this solves their
problem actually.
JEETENDRA SONEJA: Yeah.
PETE FRISELLA: Another thing
is rate limit errors.
So a lot of people get
rate-limit errors, even though
we obviously recommend that
you implement some kind of
either exponential backoff or
some other mechanism to back
off on these errors that you're
getting for rate limiting.
But aside from that, if there's
another use case that,
for example, if you are a
developer that has thousands
of users, you're actually
servicing and providing
analytics through your
application for a whole bunch
of users, if you go back to
the 10-requests-per-second
quota that we have, that's based
on IP address, right?
So if you think about it, if
you're a developer that's
doing this for a lot of users,
all your request are coming
from a single IP.
JEETENDRA SONEJA: Right.
PETE FRISELLA: So from our end
it looks like there's one user
from an IP perspective, but
you're actually doing this for
a lot of users.
So what you want to use in those
cases to make sure that
all of your users are getting
that 10 queries per second is
to use either the user IP or
quota-user parameters with
your requests.
And what that ends up doing
is for each request you're
making, you're basically
saying, I'm making this
request, but it's
for this user.
JEETENDRA SONEJA: Right.
PETE FRISELLA: And then we'll
give that full quota for that
particular user.
JEETENDRA SONEJA: Right,
that their each user
gets like 10 QPS.
PETE FRISELLA: Gets their 10
QPS, or whatever you set in
the API console, the separate
user limit will
be affected by this.
And a lot of people don't know
this exists and they're making
requests on behalf of a lot of
users, and they're hitting
that 10 QPS, even though they're
doing this for a lot
of users, right?
So this is really important
actually.
JEETENDRA SONEJA: So one of the
other problems could be
like when you look at the
API console, you see
zero requests there.
So you may be wondering,
OK, what's going on?
I'm making all these requests,
but I'm not seeing that being
reflected in the console.
So they could be one
of the two issues.
Either you're not
using OAuth 2.
If you use OAuth 2,
like I said--
PETE FRISELLA: Shouldn't
have this problem.
JEETENDRA SONEJA: Yeah, it
shouldn't have this problem.
As part of OAuth2 token, the
product ID gets propagated as
part of the request.
But if you cannot use OAuth2 for
whatever reason, there is
this IPA key that you
can find for each
project in the console.
You should use that key in the
key param with your each
request, so that all the quota
that's assigned to that
project, and you get
the full quotas.
PETE FRISELLA: Yeah, this
happens quite a bit actually.
JEETENDRA SONEJA: Yeah.
PETE FRISELLA: All right, so I
think we have a few questions.
But before we get to that, we
do have some resources.
We'll try these links below the
video, but they're also
all available on our developer
site at developers.googl
e.com/analytics.
So all this is available
for you guys.
And we do have a few
questions here.
JEETENDRA SONEJA: Yeah, we have
one question, actually,
from one of our users.
And he's talking about
upload operations.
PETE FRISELLA: OK.
JEETENDRA SONEJA: So they've
been running into 500 upload
operations per project
[INAUDIBLE] quota when
performing [INAUDIBLE].
And this typically happens with
them when they're trying
to backfill data for users.
And that's a common use case
for the upload API, right?
It's a new API, and you have
your users that have been
using these different platforms
for past couple of
years, and then you upload
all that data.
So Peter is actually--
PETE FRISELLA: Fortunately, yes,
this is one of the quotas
you can request to
have increased.
So if you go through they API's
console, go to Request
More, make the request.
And just make sure that you've
provided the project ID that
you're using, and we can
definitely take a look at
whether it makes sense to give
you a quota increase.
And we just look at the same
thing-- make sure your error
late is low, you're using a
good percentage of it--
obviously, if you're hitting
it, you're using a good
percentage of your quota.
So, yeah, that one
can be increased.
JEETENDRA SONEJA: Right.
Actually, we do have more
questions, yes.
PETE FRISELLA: OK, is there a
way to increase a 10,000 per
profile quota?
So we covered this earlier
in the presentation.
That is one of the
quotas that's
not able to be increased.
JEETENDRA SONEJA: Right.
PETE FRISELLA: I would look at
the usage and see if you can
optimize based on what we just
described here around the
common scenarios.
JEETENDRA SONEJA: Try to
consolidate requests and try
to see what kind of
requests pattern.
What data are you
trying to fetch.
Can you use additional
dimensions--
PETE FRISELLA: [INAUDIBLE].
JEETENDRA SONEJA: Exactly,
additional dimensions in the
same request additional metrics,
try to combine
multiple requests.
PETE FRISELLA: Exactly.
JEETENDRA SONEJA: Yeah,
hopefully--
PETE FRISELLA: You can get
10,000 rows per request, so I
would definitely look and see,
are you just requesting one
row of data?
And if are, then maybe there's
a way, maybe that's a sign
that there's something that you
could probably do a little
bit better.
JEETENDRA SONEJA: And if you
still have that problem, talk
to us and we can work it through
to get it resolved.
PETE FRISELLA: Sure.
So we have another one-- oh,
that's the 500 uploads.
JEETENDRA SONEJA:
So [INAUDIBLE]--
PETE FRISELLA: I don't think
that one's really
[INAUDIBLE], so.
JEETENDRA SONEJA: Yeah, I think
that's all we have.
PETE FRISELLA: That's
all have.
OK, so, again, I encourage
you go to the website.
We have most of this is covered
in documentation.
We're going to embed this
video as part of our
documentation, so you
guys can review and
reference this at any time.
And I'd like to thank you, guys,
for joining us today.
We're planning on having a few
more of these in the next
couple weeks, so please,
definitely check on our blog
and part of our G+ profile to
make sure you have the date on
what's coming out in terms
of Analytics Live.
So thanks very much
for joining us,
and have a good day.
JEETENDRA SONEJA:
Thank you all.
Bye-bye.
PETE FRISELLA: Bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]